nine people are dead after a gunman
opened fire during a Bible study at the
Emanuel African Methodist Episcopal
Church in Charleston South Carolina the
gunman was white and all of his victims
black if it wasn't already apparent to
many the Charleston Police Chief wasted
little time in saying I do believe this
was a hate crime hate crime means the
killer was motivated by racial prejudice
but doesn't it go deeper the shooting
happened in a state with a legacy of
slavery in a country that's confronting
systemic racism and at a time when
communities are rallying around the
slogan black lives matter these are
murders that will reverberate for years
to come
the gunman is 21 year old Dylan roof
those patches on his jacket the symbols
of the South African apartheid state and
the British breakaway colony Rhodesia
which also practice racist white
minority rule until indigenous blacks
won independence in 1979 and renamed it
Zimbabwe
he's also been pictured with a
confederate flag which still waves on
the grounds of the South Carolina State
Capitol remember South Carolina was the
first state to secede from the Union in
1861 in defense of slavery roof was
arrested the next morning in North
Carolina just before President Obama
addressed the country and made the
connection between mass shootings and a
lack of gun control let's be clear at
some point we as a country will have to
reckon with the fact that this type of
mass violence does not happen in other
advanced countries it doesn't happen in
other places with this kind of frequency
the Charleston community has suffered a
huge loss sadness
partake for the families their friends
you know our take from the urge to be
taken history period AME Church she
decided to come in
just kill nine people randomly for no
reason
and it just ratio and then me to stop
because of a lot of black people
didn't care about among the victims was
a high school track coach a librarian
and the pastor clementa pinckney a 41
year old democratic state senator who
had been serving in the legislature
since 96 he was a leader in racial
justice movements back in April he spoke
out against the police killing of Walter
Scott when we first heard on the
television that a police officer had
gunned down an unarmed african-american
in North Charleston by the name of
Walter Scott there was some who said wow
the national story has come home to
South Carolina
but the Emanuel AME Church isn't just
any Church it was founded in 1816 and
houses one of the oldest black
congregations in the United States in
1822 one of the church's founders was
accused of being involved in a slave
revolt plot and was executed with five
others the original Church was then
burned down by white supremacists in
1834 all black churches were outlawed in
Charleston and the congregation had to
meet in secret until the end of the
Civil War and during the civil rights
movement in the 1960s it was a
destination for many leaders including
Martin Luther King jr. with these
killings the church continues to be a
symbol of black struggle many are
comparing the massacres to another crime
that galvanized the civil rights
movement the 1963 bombing of a
Birmingham Church that killed four
little girls this is about the first
time that black churches have been
attacked and we know that hatred across
races and faiths pose a particular
threat to our democracy and our ideals
many people in this country don't like
to think about this history but for
others it's not history at all people
just like other people we are
communities trying to live and survive
why do we have to live like
we have enough tissues in our jaws we
don't need more we need peace